joining me now is Georgia State Rep
Misha Maynor who left the Democrat Party
earlier this year and Daniel e friends a
campus reform correspondent uh
representative we've talked before about
why you left the Democrat Party but now
seeing how things have gotten even worse
just over the past few months what's
your message to those Democrats who are
still just complaining about messaging
and maybe not getting enough money like
Eric Adams but not really focusing on
the policies themselves that are driving
this decline in despair
the answer is to focus on the policies
we cannot continue to put politics over
people at the end of the day the people
are actually screaming saying we are not
happy with this you are taking our
resources away and putting them in
places we don't want them if they would
just listen to the voters they could
have a chance but it's what I'm doing
right now is going out into my community
and really just exposing the truth to
them and their listening well Daniel
we've seen African-Americans in Chicago
Express their total outrage about how
the migrants are soaking up all this
money a 30 million dollars a month and
by some estimation and you in New York
City where you're where you're living
what are you seeing there and how do you
respond to the concerns about crime and
uh and filth and all the other problems
that the migrant population had brought
to the city and why is Eric Adams not
talking about the border and not just
money
yeah it's insane as a son of legal
Haitian immigrants I am it outraged I
live in New York City all my life for 19
years I've wanted better trains better
schooling but cleaner streets better
policing me and all the residents of New
York has gotten none of those things but
the moment illegal immigrants come to
our city they get free hotel rooms and
they get health care it's insane as a
writing for campus reform I can tell you
this is happening in cities Across
America universities are even giving
College to uh illegal immigrants free
tuition is a slap in the face to my
parents and parents Across America who
sacrifice a lot for their kids
uh representative we heard this before
though before the midterm election that
African-Americans and other Americans
were very upset by crime very upset
about the border and really worried
about the economy but there wasn't that
much of a shift in the voting patterns
um among those uh minority voters so
they they seem outraged in polls but on
the turnout and on the on the vote
changes you're not seeing that much
movement how do you get them to the
polls and to finally break with the
Democrat Party
I think opportunities like this Laura at
the end of the day you have me on a
national platform and they're going to
be African-Americans and they're going
to be Democrats that are listening to
this message everything that you just
said prior to bringing us on a sat here
laughing because it really makes no
sense what you were saying like how did
we even get to this spot where we are
allowing foolishness to rule our country
and so I'm going to continue to educate
the people in my district people like
Daniel other leaders and other
Representatives that are changing their
minds we really need to collectively put
our voice together because if we don't
we're going to lose this country faster
than you think yeah and Republicans have
to actually go into these areas and go
into these neighborhoods and not be
afraid to spend you know actually speak
to people about their concerns and what
the solutions are that that's got to
happen
um Daniel new data from the center
Survey Center on American Life shows
that black Americans especially younger
ones ages 18 to 49 are souring on Biden
and just 36 percent now believe he
accomplished a good or great deal 21
want him as the 2024 nominee in less
than half 48 percent identify as
Democrat
is the dam finally breaking
I think the dam is finally breaking
Laura I am sick of tired of the rhetoric
that I do not have agency in this
country and plenty of other young black
Americans believed the same a big
example is affirmative action I do not
want to be told that I need
some sort of Equitable policy to be in a
great institution I want to own my
accomplishments and my shortcomings in
America
uh it's great to have you both on
tonight thank you so much representative
Maynor and Daniel hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else